hey guys goodness I have a fitness app
you get to workout life with me and
other amazing trainers every single day
go on done appear on the App Store or go
to fear live.com and start your journey
to become hey guys welcome back to
another workout once that subtle app
crack which will make you look good in
crop-top
here's a seven minute ab workout so
there will be three circuits we will
repeat each circuit two rounds through
without stopping each workout will be
for 30 seconds long and we will move on
to the next workout for another 30
seconds without any rest okay there will
be a 30 seconds rest in between circuits
three circuits only seven minutes so
time to get that rock-solid app ready
for summer let's go right lie down on
your mat the first workout is going to
be a rerun CH like straight down okay
spread your legs apart what I'm going to
do is bring your hands together over
your shoulders over your head and as you
crunch up spread your legs and bring
your hands in between your legs okay
it's going to be B a V crunch working on
your upper as well as your lower abs the
second workout is going to be a plank
run let's go crunch up 30 seconds
point your toes crunch up back down and
lift it up okay spread your legs you
will also be working on your outer
thighs as well as your obliques squeeze
it whoo and up squeeze it lift your
shoulders off the mat okay keep your
legs as straight as possible no get back
up into a plane and just rock forward
and back okay suck your belly in tighten
your core Rock forward and back
good we want to work on your upper your
lower as well as your obliques and back
into the crunch okay rock forward and
back on your toes stay on your toes
forward and back few more last one more
and back down into V crunch
spread your legs up crunch it up bring
them together crunch up together and up
beginners if this is difficult
you can choose to bend your knees up
lift your shoulders off the floor good
as wide as you can
nice last few more one more and back up
let's get into play rock ok good rock
forward and back keep going keep
breathing through the workout
all right strong plank keep your back
flat and push into the ground okay and
we want to move on to the second circuit
you're almost there
last one and drop your knees now
let's sit down on your butt for the next
second is going to be a crunchy frog
with criss-cross scissors okay so start
on your butt stay on your part what I
wait to do is lift both legs up spread
your arms hug your knees in spread it
out and hug your knees close in okay
simple as that
beginners you can drop your heels to the
floor okay
ready let's go spread it out hug your
knees in drop your knees and hug it in
if not point your toes hug it in
find your balance tighten your core hug
it in and hug it in okay don't rush the
workout this is not an easy workout but
it will give you strong ABS
hug it in I get in if you need to drop
your legs hug it in drop it hug it drop
it and hug it good and let's lie down
see this crisscross
okay so crisscross let's go up and let's
go down
and now let's go back up straight legs
and back down suck your belly in
okay tighten it do not arch your lower
back plus one and back into crunchy Rock
get up okay sit on your butt find a
balance straight back hug it in out haq
and haq good spread your arms nice and
control
I'll get hot good last few more huh drop
a huge hug and now back down
Ceaser's criss cross let's go up
back up straight legs
point your toes keep going last one
alright and we're moving on to the third
circuit alright okay for the third
second is going to be our lakes double
pulse switch okay all right it's still
light down what I'm going to do is bring
both legs straight forward lift one leg
up as you come up pulse twice switch
bring it up pulse twice okay that's it
and the final workout is going to be a
mini wiper let's go up pulse it switch
pulse switch and pulse if you want to
keep your legs in the air
okay breathe in and out when your knees
slightly and pack it down all right so
get back up it's going to be a mini
wiper so just imagine you have something
in the middle what I want to do is cross
your leg over over and cross it that's
it
so side to side working on your obliques
drop it side to side
nice drop it drop it and drop it good
that's it and now back down all right
let's go
pulse to switch you have the option to
drop your legs down onto the floor okay
pulse up crunch up as high as you can
lifting your shoulders off the floor
bring it down up all right bring it up
crunch it up last one more one more and
come back up this is your final workout
okay let's go cross over drop it mini
wipers drop it and cross good when your
knees slightly
cross it over imagine you're drawing a
rainbow cross it tap gently one more on
each side drop it drop it and rest it
out okay well done so that was a really
quick seven minute ab workout okay do it
consistently if you want to you can
repeat each circuit three times
remember combine this workout with total
body workouts you have to do your total
body cardio and you have to do your
total body strength training as well
they give this video a thumbs up be sure
to subscribe to my youtube channel
check out my other ab workouts on my
channel as well as crazy at challenges
and I do also have a fitness app check
out a few on the App Store or the Google
Play Store where I'll be sharing monthly
workout plans and meal plans to guide
you through your fitness journey plus
you will get a chance to win amazing
prizes
or the best